these fundamental problems that that
beset California have to be addressed
and the governor's tried to address them
since a day took office
hi I'm Tim Cavanaugh for reason TV it's
the fall of 2010 and once again
california state budget is many months
overdue state workers are facing
furloughs layoffs and pay cuts
everywhere you look in this city around
us you can see the effects of deep and
painful spending cuts so why is all of
this good news because the budget talks
are just part of a larger struggle to
solve California's half trillion dollar
public pension crisis nationwide the
unfunded liability is three trillion
dollars the amounts the road for
pensions are owed come hell or high
water unconditionally David Crane also
known as the cranium and mr. pension has
been an advisor to Governor Arnold
Schwarzenegger through most of his two
terms during that time the governor has
tried pension reform and tried pension
and retirement dead to fight the power
of the state's public sector unions for
the most part the unions have one so
while Schwarzenegger Republicans and
even some Democrats want to solve the
pension crisis they haven't been able to
do anything about it until now
Californians are paying higher taxes and
fees for fewer government services and
they're hopping mad about government
employees lavish pay and pension
packages these fundamental problems that
that beset California have to be
addressed and the governor's tried to
address them since a day took office and
those problems are not something that
happened just this year last year
they're derived from things that
happened years ago this is not between
Democrats and Republicans I don't even
look at that at all with less than three
months left in office Schwarzenegger has
made permanent pension reform as top
priority even if that means leaving
Sacramento without a budget signed just
one problem the pension crisis dates
back to a law Senate bill 400 that was
signed more than a decade ago by
Schwarzenegger predecessor well sb400
which was passed in the late 1990s under
the administration of Gray Davis suit
significantly boosted pensions not only
for
and new employees prospectively but it
boosted every pension for every existing
state worker it was the largest issuance
of debt in California history and it was
issued without voter approval or voter
knowledge it was a stunning issuance of
debt and what it did was retro actively
as well as prospectively and statutorily
increased pension benefits for then
existing government employees including
people who are going to be retiring the
next day state Senate Minority Leader
Dennis Hollingsworth has introduced
several bills to repeal sb400 and
related laws there was an analysis by
CalPERS and the analysis basically said
that things are going to continue rosy
in the stock market we expect things
will continue the way that they were in
late 1990s and early two thousand and
that that you would not see any
contribution to stabilizing the fund by
the taxpayers through the budget process
in excess of about a hundred and fifty
million dollars for about a decade or
more what we found now is that that was
so far off that we're actually looking
at about four billion dollars this year
coming out of the budget for stabilizing
the pension system the problem has
gotten so severe that even some public
sector unions have begun to compromise I
think what our members were looking for
was security times are extremely
difficult right now this summer six
public unions negotiated contracts with
the governor that effectively took new
higher pensions back to their pre 1999
levels Bob wolf president of the
forestry firefighters union explains why
you know gives us you know gives you
comfort you can go for the next three
years knowing that your family save your
career save and it gives three more
years for the economy to turn around but
the bulk of state worker unions have not
been willing to compromise on the
pensions that are eating up an ever
larger piece of the budget many
progressives including San Francisco
public defender Jeff Adachi and
union-friendly career politician Willie
Brown have come to understand how
pension payments suck up funds for their
own causes employee pensions and
care costs that's one out of every five
dollars that's being spent but public
employee unions still wield the
political power in this overwhelmingly
democratic state the power rests with my
party with the Democratic Party because
its democratic programs programs that
tend to be favored by Democrats Higher
Education Health and Human Services
Environmental Protection parks and
recreation all of those programs are the
programs that are squeezed out by
drawing pension costs that's where our
budget works so the state doesn't go
broke it just takes more money from
other programs so while California's
budget debate looks ugly it's putting
pressure where it's needed most directly
on government employees certainly the
pressure because of the budget deficits
that we keep having for them to get to
the table and negotiate pensions that
are less generous comes from things like
the furloughs it comes from things like
the the threat of having to go to a
minimum wage with the absence of a
budget right now the legislature and the
governor are working on a framework
budget agreement that reportedly
includes a rollback of sb400 and the
mechanism to prevent the practice of
pension spiking it may be the last
battle for Governor Schwarzenegger but
it's the first of many for the bankrupt
and beleaguered golden state pension
costs are rising they're doubling every
four and a half years that's going to
happen even with reform but the question
is for how long will they keep doubling
in four and a half or and a half years
without reform they'll double with that
rate forever for raising TV I am Tim
Cavanaugh
you